السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
الجامعه الجامعه
وفي وقت الفراغ صاحبه رشحناه الكتاب ولكم
في حياتي من خلال كتاب
نظمها والناجحين من حول العالم موجب سود
ان يكون واحد منهم الكتاب ده كان بالنسبه
فبالتجدد سلسله الكتب لحد ما وصلت
دي كان بالنسبه
المفروض يكون عنده اهداف
في الكتب دي مره بمقوله
كتير جدا
واحد ثان الصباح
واحد من الساعه 3:00 الجامعه 20
في 2020 شارك في مسابقه الروبوتات الاولى
في السودان اول مسابقه رسميه بالنسبه
فكروا مني يمشي الصباح وغدر يعمل
صباح مغني اخذ الكيبور
د
اليوم مليان من حماس اكتشفوا
بيدربوه
وتحدث
[موسيقى]
الاول انه يستسلم
انه نهايه المسابقه عند خط النهايه وليس
في اول عرض
منتظرين ويبحث عن حلول يوم الحل من فريق
بسبب مشكله في الروابط غير المتحكم اخذوا
المتحكمه وبدر يشتغل بالانجليزي
من ناحيه الكتابه
[موسيقى]
صح يعني
50% من الحسابات
كله
على الحافه
[موسيقى]
في النهايه حصل على الميداليه البروزيه في
المسابقه
[موسيقى]
جاءت عام 2021
يارب
من 40 دوله حول
[موسيقى]
بعد يومين انه
تمثيل السودان
مركز مركز
[موسيقى]
لانه في اكتوبر
وانقطع عن كل السودان
وكانت وزير التواضع الوحيده بينهم قطر
وبك احتمال يكون
مستحيل تعرف
[تصفيق]
شيء مسافه 30 كلم 30 كلم
اسبوع ودي مسافه
ويفتح الايميل المشكله
ما بعرف لا كان احد بالمواصلات كان بيطلع
امشي كلمه جدعه جديده برجلينا وهو ماشي
كلام باذن الله
الثعلب بالنسبه لهم هو الكلام بتخطي
الاسئله وبحاول ما يتركز بس بيعمل كل
العيله كان بيعمل خطوه بخطوه كان عنده
ايام عديدهم المط
جاهز على كل الاجراءات المطلوبه اليوم
الاول
[موسيقى]
زي المره الاولى كانوا بيقول نعم نعم
شارك في الملتقى وبالنهايه الملتقى حصل
على الميلاديه الطبيه بالمربعين دوله من
حول العالم
يه مجانيه في الاتحاد الدولي للمستمعين
وحصل عن اللبن مختلف
الاف الدولارات بالاضافه للمطلبات اللازمه
للحصول
على السودان
الجديد مخترع
بعقليه مختلفه
جائزه قيمه للناس الحوالين
في المجتمع
يستعمل المشروع التخرج عشان يعمل جهاز
يستعملين كر
سي المنطقه عشان يرجعوا يمشوا على غيرهم
كل الاجابات
[موسيقى]
بل نديره
دي كلها
[موسيقى]
اسمه يوسف
اشتغل اشتغل
[تصفيق]
للسنه 2021 2020 حاضر
حليمه موجود معنا
عبد الرحمن
[تصفيق]
ان شاء الله
بالمشروع ده حصلت على جوائز ومداليات
ودروع مختلفه وبالاضافه لتكريم المدرسه
الخاصه وتكريم من بنك النيل وتكريم من
عمليه كليه الهندسه عن السودان وتكريم
واداء الجامعه الاسلاميه
[تصفيق]